hi I'm Nicolas be with reason TV and
today we're talking with Arnold cling
and Nick Schultz co-authors of from
poverty to prosperity intangible assets
hidden liabilities and the lasting
triumph over scarcity thanks for coming
guys you right in you right at the
beginning of the book that economics is
not what it used to be and you draw a
distinction between economics 1 point 0
and economics 2 point 0 can you talk a
little bit about what what's behind that
typology all right I'll take a shot and
you take a shot the these are economists
who don't make it into the mainstream
media even though you know they're
perfectly respectable of the ten
economists that we interviewed four of
them won Nobel prizes two of them are
often listed as potential Prize winners
and the other four or no slackers either
but the media ignore them more
importantly the mainstream media ignore
their ideas so but we mean by economics
2 point 0 is they focus on intangibles
typical economics 1 point 0 says well
there's labor there's land there's
capital and these people focus on
institutions things like property rights
and so on and also on ideas innovation
as fact and these are the intangible you
write that economics 1 point 0 looks at
the market as a mechanism for allocating
a given amount of resources economics to
point out of the market is a mechanism
for stimulating and filtering innovation
that when i read that and of course in
the book you you give props to joseph
schumpeter but it seems very coming out
of a shampoo tyrion tradition of that
you know the gales of creative
destruction are not about taking a set
number of goods and distributing them
but constantly creating new ways of
meeting or creating needs and demands
and desires right I think that's fair
and and it gets to an important point an
important theme of the book which is how
you would think about problem solving
how you would think about challenges
that our face so if you if you think
that the world is a sort of fixed pie
at what you needed to do is move around
parts of it over here or parts of it
over there that's going to lead to one
set of kind of policy responses say in
the context of politics but if you
instead say that well problems can be
solved by innovation by new products by
new processes it opens up and enlarge is
how you might look at the world how you
might look at political problems how you
look at social problems how you think
about economic development and the like
so it's a it's I think a subtle but
important reorientation and how people
look at the world around them in the
province of the base and I think it's
important how innovation takes place
there's a central conflict throughout
the book between what Bill easterly
calls searchers and planners so there
are people who rely on plans that's
large bureaucracies large organizations
and there are people who rely on trial
and error and I guess this is something
like reasontv if they were trying to
launch that out of a large network like
CNN or NBC there would be this gigantic
committee of vice presidents involved
and there would be years of planning and
probably the budget for xeroxing
PowerPoint decks would be bigger than
everything you've spent so far whereas
you're probably just trying to throw
things against the wall try a different
things try different revenue models and
what have you and that's that's the way
most innovation takes place which we
have thought about a revenue bottle
Constance that's a gaping hole in our
plan or our searching you mentioned pie
talk about how food is an example of a
triumph over scarcity well 11 de this is
actually Arnold's line but I'll bring it
up one way of illustrating the dynamic
that we're talking about is if you
looked at economic problems say four or
five generations ago and you want to
teach young people about economic
problems that they face you may give
them the grapes of wrath but today if
you wanted to talk about the plight of
the poor you might suggest supersize me
so we we now have especially in
developed countries abundance is becomes
in a certain sense its own problem we've
solved so many economic problems that
we had a new set of challenges it's not
that they aren't challenges I mean there
are obese people and this is something
you have to deal with but it's a
categorically different kind of problem
that you're doing with then say in the
1920s do you follow a shampoo Tyrion
line and he was he was he influenced
other critiques of capitalism that you
know one of the ways that capitalism
goes away is because people get too fat
and lazy and they forget how wealth is
created and how it is you know how a
society is nourished are you negative
about the the move to a post-scarcity
world good I'll take that I you know
I've thought a lot about that and I used
to be but I'm not anymore one reason is
that saying the United States culturally
the entrepreneurial culture here is very
strong so yes for some people that may
be the case were relatively successful
we have most of our basic needs met will
people then continue driving striving
and innovating but you know the cultural
makeup of the country is such that I
don't think that's that's a problem
you're still going to have people who
want to innovate want to try new things
want to experiment and those sorts of
things are going to provided that that
people can continue to do that are going
to continue to drive along run
innovation so I'm not not worried about
at least in the context the United
States well you know the book doesn't
actually answer that question it's a
good question but the the economics two
point oh very much emphasizes the role
of culture and the individual attitudes
in kind of shaping the economy and so
you know some of the economics that
we've learned over the last 50 years
it's just how important that culture is
you can't just sort of go into Iraq and
change the culture overnight or go into
an African country and change the
culture overnight and hopefully you
can't go enjoy Michigan right check out
the culture overnight is this a good
time to write and release a book about
the lasting triumph over scarcity yeah
it's counterintuitive least we've joked
the runt of the book that maybe we
should call from poverty to prosperity
and back to poverty again but you know
it's it's
somewhat counterintuitive but I think
you know one of the things of the book
is that a lot of the gains are pretty
lasting I mean obviously we're in the
middle of a pretty rough economic time
but I remember going to Japan for
example the first time many many years
ago after Japan had this Lost Decade
right and I kept thinking well I'm going
to go there's going to be this horribly
depressed society and no energy no vigor
and you go there you would have no idea
coming from the outside so that there
are gains that can be made that that can
be lasting and I do think that this
triumph over over scarcities is real and
and it's an important story and it's
it's an underappreciated one and a
useful exercise and actually gave this
to my high school students is to do a
plot of real gross domestic product or
real gross domestic product per person
over a long period from let's say that
you know as far back as we have the data
till now and every recession in that
plot shows up as a tiny little blip now
this one will show up as a bigger blip
but it'll still be you know 10 15 years
and out from now it'll still appear to
be a relatively tiny blip in a lot of
ways the problems from this will be less
the kind of evaporation of capital and
more the legacy of the rules and
regulations of the institutional changes
that get made absolutely and of course I
describe this I'm known for describing
this as the great recalculation meaning
that there are there going to be
dramatic movements out of some
industries and into others on top of
this you have a new book another new
book yes I call that book too it's
called unchecked and unbalanced and it's
about the discrepancy that's emerging
between knowledge being highly dispersed
and specialized while power political
power is becoming more concentrated and
neck you're the editor in chief of the
American American Enterprise Institute
publication how does that carry through
the themes of your book well well what
we focus a lot on at American com on
economic growth and another issue that
is that as big in this book and is
important to me which is
entrepreneurship it's by noemi one of
the things that we want want the book to
do is to point areas that people should
be looking at and spending more time
thinking about because we're not
presenting this as well here's these you
know set view of the world instead it is
here are areas of academic research of
just intellectual research that people
should be doing spending more attention
to spending more time on and we do a lot
of that at the American and so that's
how the two time together well and it's
certainly clear that we are desperately
in need of new economic frameworks and
kind of philosophical frameworks and
probably even epistemological framework
since a lot of the explanations
emanating from DC whether it's
conservative or liberal don't seem to be
capturing reality as we experience I
want to thank Arnold cling and Nick
Schultz authors of from poverty to
prosperity intangible assets hidden
liabilities in the lasting triumph over
scarcity and I would also like to thank
Washington DC for supplying more than
enough ambient noise during this
interview for reason TV I'm Nick
Gillespie
you